the Islamic state caliphate is all but
gone there is instead mile after mile of
destroyed communities where once the
extremists had absolute power spread
across two countries an area the size of
Britain there's now just rubble the
militants have often left booby traps
and mines as they retreat so we're
ordered to walk in a line bunker we come
in right inside a tunnel this is very
typical of Islamic state digging tunnels
and they also had smashed through holes
in the wall so they could get from
building to building so there's lots of
drones ahead is has been cornered on one
small patch of land boxed in on all
sides
our cameras catch them frantically
making preparations for what's being
called their last stand
women and children can be seen there too
there's a lull in the battle the is
fighters say they're holding prisoners
they want to make a deal is retreated
and retreated quickly and many appear to
have been foreign nationals
signs are if a family probably stayed
here because there are small toys left
behind there's blankets and a pillow and
in this suitcase there's a Calvin Klein
watch woman's glove part of a book with
which was French a French what appears
to be part of a diary or a letter in
which the writer talks about all the
amputations all the injuries the torture
and imprisonment is worth it for alle
and a child's drawing showing the
Islamic flag and a plane dropping bombs
on houses and some sort of weaponry in
return
some families are making it out down and
humanitarian corridor into the desert
where US coalition soldiers are waiting
to interview them there are clearly some
war wounded amongst them this man has a
badly burned face shrapnel injuries and
a fractured arm which has received some
sophisticated medical aid another man
says he lost both his legs after
stepping on a mine they're all
considered is suspects the men are
segregated and fingerprinted before
being taken off to a detention center
where they'll be interrogated the women
will be taken to a camp where they'll
stay under guard
- until decisions are taken about what
to do with them there are several
foreigners amongst them a French
teenager called Anissa who's 19 and from
Dunkirk and who now has a one-year-old
baby I was 15 I was I was not big in my
head I talk in internet and I and I
follow only one week is eternity very
much the Internet and after I go I don't
think good I I do this fast and after I
came I I even I I didn't know that it
was her war I didn't when I came here I
hear bombs and I was so scared I say I
saywhat this because the men who called
me talk with me he didn't he did say to
me that it's war here Lydia for him is
also French from Paris
she married twice in Syria and has two
children she says both husbands were
killed in the fighting but despite it
all she says she learned a lot I regret
and I don't regret I will get because it
was not my
my way to think I came here without
knowledge and knowledge very important
since Lam and I didn't we good because
this makes me experience to be strong
and to be mother and to be very strong
they both yearn to go home to France but
that's a very long way away right now
there are a handful of detention camps
spread across Northeast Syria now home
to thousands of suspected is families
and those here have found it's not so
easy getting out this is where all the
women and children who were married or
belong to Isis fighters are being kept
it's basically a prison under guard 24
hours they're not allowed out there are
at least four British women and their
children staying on this campus really
and I even this are didn't want to at
all because of the bad experience they
didn't want to be filmed but many have
found themselves here for more than a
year already among those being held as
suspected is fighters is a man from
Birmingham Anwar Mir
hi Alex Crawford from Sky News when we
met him on a Kurdish base with guards
overseeing us he insisted it was all a
mistake I can say to them everybody in
Britain I'm not I'm not I'm not an Isis
fighter I'm not a dangerous person I
came here to do humanitarian work I have
hurt nobody
I have done nothing wrong I've been
working in a hospital people have
labeled me with Isis because of the area
was controlled by Isis but I just did my
job
working in a hospital
for three and a half years he was inside
is territory when the extremists were at
their strongest controlling large areas
of land in Syria and Iraq carrying out
executions amputations and the headings
but the birmingham pharmacist insists he
saw virtually nothing when I first got
the internet was always very weak and
then they weren't to appear Dubai they
said the Internet is not allowed and
then they said the television is not
allowed and they took they removed
everybody's dishes and they put him in
one place and it was it was forbidden to
have a television in your house wasn't
that a bit of an alarm bell that things
might be going wrong in May and
everything was fine but the coalition of
Western governments including Britain
which supported the fight against is are
now refusing to repatriate citizens like
Mohammad on one year claiming they could
carry out attacks back home what is it
you miss about Britain I miss everything
the choice the choice you know and the
freedom the choice and the freedom you
know I can I can walk into a supermarket
and everything is available I can have
the freedom to choose anything I want
his brother back home in Britain who saw
his sibling on Sky News urged the
British authorities to help rescue him
I'm very worried you know things are
changing over there the situation as in
you know who's got control and I mean I
don't know we don't know what will
happen to him we don't know his favour
you know and there's no indication of
you know where it's going towards
so the your left your left in a sort of
like a limbo where you know anything can
happen and it can be it can he might
have a bad ending I'm not a danger I'm
not a danger I came here to do
humanitarian work he's asked us to keep
his identity hidden for fear of angry
reprisals against his family but he said
no
out of his brothers innocence he's just
the same he's just the same person that
on you you know with pure intentions you
know very honest and there's not even
that doubt in my mind whenever from any
information I get or when I hear him
there's not even that little doubt in my
mind to question his sort of like his
honesty or you know his intentions the
Kurdish forces holding the is suspects
hadn't been able to conduct trials and
don't want the responsibility of people
they view as militants especially with
the region so fragile their foreign
captives are in limbo and getting
desperate we also spoke to a doctor
who'd worked in the NHS for eight years
now also being held by the coalition in
Northeast Syria he says he was duped
into crossing into Syria ended up being
kidnapped and sold to is he to wants the
British authorities to bring him home
why am I still sitting in the prison why
I'm not being given any justice is there
no justice Britain exists is the
strongest one of the strongest countries
in the world and why my country has
abandoned me when I needed it the most
the doctor says he spent two years in
and out of eius jails and on the run in
fear of his life before the coalition
captured him I never realized how much I
would miss my home how much England
meant to me really so for me it is my
home I was a very good doctor a good
profession a good human being there is
not a single complaint in NHS against me
I've been excellent with people and I
have got some special skills Alexander
but Mears if' is an Irish passport
holder who's lived in Dublin but left
for Syria in 2013 urging his wife to
bring their baby son and join him months
later what can I do it's the biggest
mistake of my life what what else I lost
half years I still [ __ ] half years
from my family he and his family emerged
weakened starving a few weeks ago from
the last pocket held by is he insists he
was forced by eius to drive injured
people to hospitals they told me he must
have worked now I can't sit like that I
said well and I'm gonna go fight it I
can't first of all I physically I can do
this I said no we're not asking you to
fight I have to like bring the feminists
to the hospitals in maybe sometime I'll
Bob sometime Rocca and that's what I did
for over a year towards the end towards
the last six months it wasn't like this
you don't fight you don't eat I didn't
fight
I didn't eat I eat grass my family eat
grass the worry now is in the dying days
at the battle against is his Kurdish
captors may lose territory to either
Turkey or the Syrian regime's Basham
al-assad and that'll mean losing control
of their foreign prisoners well I don't
know if you're gonna ending up in their
custody of Bashar you're gonna get
killed this is definitely he will kill
us the military fight against is maybe
all but over
but the regions as unstable as ever and
thousands accused of being foreign
Islamic state fighters are wanted by
neither their home countries or their
captors Alex Crawford Sky News in
eastern Syria